[Music]
four six what's your favorite podcast
my favorite podcast um
i listened to rogan wrong answer it's
this one what the hell oh
no go ahead you can finish yeah i'm
gonna let you finish um
i listen to rogan when it's like one of
my friends are on or a guest is on
and isn't rogan your friends all the
time yeah all the exact exactly it's my
favorite
i do listen to rogue it does to me
podcasts are starting to feel a little
bit like
homework there's a lot of them you know
like i gotta listen to this thing oh
these two people have this conversation
i gotta like see what they said you know
do you only listen to them for
information never for fun um
yeah probably i i i i feel like i'll
talk to you in real life i want to have
fun
i'll uh listen to that um the new york
times the daily
i try to listen to because i i don't
know how to get news
where am i getting news i'm not i'm not
trying to
i'm not making a joke it's a real
question i'm asking you
i use the news app from apple yeah
well where do they get the news
everywhere that's why i use that but
android or whatever does have a good
news section it could be a lie but it's
good either way
i'm in a i'm in a a paranoid state about
the news
where i'm like i don't did you want to
ask me what my favorite podcast was
no i want to this one trick question i
don't have to ask i i'm going to ask you
in a second but i would like to
leave today having a news outlet to go
to
okay then just google the news no but
that's not
the algorithm is making it so buying
what news do you need to know what are
you doing
what what do you need to know there's a
lot of things i
name one i have not been
engaging in the news let me tell you
dinosaurs extinct
people still getting married babies
still being delivered pandemic still
happening you're caught up
what it's true
news is not that healthy is it i mean
like what what do you need to know what
is this
most news has nothing to do with our
lives where we are as in
yeah like we don't have to look at the
news every morning it's a weird
addiction like doom scrolling yeah you
know who watches the news every morning
my grumpy ass grandfather
yeah you don't really know watches every
morning he doesn't even know what's
going on he just said stuff like
well look at her she's still blonde
ain't she
like what that's so funny
the news like i'm not really listening
i'm just roasting the person giving me
the news
he'll just be like he's not working here
you don't work and where you don't work
there
like she wears a lot of makeup i'm not
even looking at the weather i'm just
critiquing the weather girl
in l.a i mean that's that's such a
funny point it's like i just feel like
i'm
after having covid and being online so
much i feel like i'm just like
disconnected and i don't know what's
going on anything i need to know
somebody will tell me
a friend my mom i'll get a text
my news is whatever my life is that day
i wake up i look outside this is my news
it says the weather like your news yeah
that is i mean my
i don't even know everybody's news i
don't know what's happening in my day
what's the weather where am i going how
are you that's the only thing i need to
know
honestly that is such a good way to go
through life
yeah like there's the news none of my
business was it killer hornets we had
murder hornets
i don't see any so none of my business
yeah that's not my problem
news really is just going here's a
problem you can't solve that doesn't
apply to you
just want you to know about it yeah this
may kill you tonight at seven well
i might kill myself by seven who knows
let's stress you out
for no reason at all this is what the
news is
that is a little bit like and then
there's like stuff at the bottom i have
to read and decide and have to go to the
app to find out something else and then
i have to sign up for alerts like
no i took a break from the news and i'm
i'm a happier person
i've never worked have you noticed i'm
happy you never watch the news no
i just told you i know i take great
pride in uh
uh being interested in not being updated
if i hear a topic everyone's talking
about i look it up myself and i read
about it
so so i want to start my day with new
information
i don't i'm still trying to process
yesterday i have shit to do today
i can't be worried about what's what's
killing me if i can use my cell phone by
a gas pump remember that
what when we couldn't use cell phones by
gas pumps
was that real did you not live in the
90s
uh yeah i was early 2000s really i was
like in debt from buying you didn't have
a cell phone got it oh yeah so well yeah
you couldn't use them by gas pumps for a
long time probably still can't
microwaves they were killing us at one
point
benden has all these like random
traumas that are so funny what was the
thing you said the other
day what was it emily when she he was
like uh we're talking about something
he's like oh yeah and then that that
then when i saw that dead body and
you're like what like you'll say
what were we talking about you said
something that was just like so flippant
yeah i can't remember it wasn't about
the groundhog
what's that when i was riding my go-kart
and the groundhog ran into my lap and i
crashed to the barn
what exactly it's my point exactly i
just had this go-kart and i would drive
around our barn
and one time literally i was driving and
a groundhog ran like trying to run
across what is that first of all
it's a groundhog hold on i've never seen
you no you're not gonna ask what are the
groundhog i've never seen a groundhog in
person
whitney it comes out every year and
looks at its shadow what do you mean
you know for the holiday in a bill
murray
movie i've seen it in a movie i've never
seen a groundhog i know what a like a
warthog
well they're like a little fuzzy big
mice they're almost like a like a beaver
but on the tail
yeah the okay one ran out and it got in
my lap and i was like probably
11 or something and it was like it ran
and the go-kart was going fast enough
you were like a fair no i was just
riding my go-kart around
around the barn go kart i thought
go-karts are when you
bump bumper cars this fog is deep
you know what a go-kart is now no i know
it's a small car with no walls no i
can't
like what do you i don't understand how
a groundhog would jump into your lap
so i was going at it i was going at a
go-kart speed the groundhog was running
but the timing it would ran into my lap
doesn't scare the shit of me it doesn't
oh
we call my mom fine and i drove through
the barn can you call it a caller
what time is it there oh it's 10.
i you might be mad
i don't i don't buy it i don't buy that
that the same time that a cart was going
that a cart was going that a groundhog
would have hit
which is why the story is shocking
that's what makes the story shocking yes
that's the part of the story
that's why it's a story hi mama we're
filming um
the podcast i have a question because
when you don't believe me do you
remember when i was uh
little and that groundhog ran into the
go-kart and then i crashed in the barn
yes okay i just want to confirm that
thank you are you asleep
yes oh sorry okay bye no oh no i'm sorry
we're not leaving we have more questions
there's more questions mom on the line
uh not gonna waste this hi
oh she said hi mom hi i have so much to
ask you
okay well you're breathing kind of heavy
so we're going to let you go
i love i'm like i'm like star struck by
meeting bethan's mom
okay well love you too i love you baby
all right love you so
much oh come on
we don't say bob we say tata that's
forever
i'm starting to get my energy back you
know what it is i feel like um
this is gonna sound dramatic but i feel
like covid like broke my heart
this is a good way to end it i'm just
saying i think it like broke my spirit i
feel like i need to get my spirit back
how are you gonna do that i don't know
i'm gonna
join some suggestions from the fans i
know yeah maybe i i like i
feel i don't know if it's just like a
general thing where everyone's like oh
it's been a year
there's like a everyone i talk to right
now is like just feeling like
this extra layer of depression right now
maybe i'm just projecting
um but yeah i'm gonna like get through
it
good you should you know people are
looking forward to that
that me being like funny again and back
and clear no just feeling better
clear-headed oh me being functional i
think they're super excited i think
people are tuning in for that
okay well i'll be back soon um we did uh
this
podcast with laura wasser she's the
biggest lawyer in the world i've been
obsessed with her for ages
she's a badass genius icon legend genius
icon legend star
um she's like she represents every
celebrity in their big divorce it's not
just celebrities but
um she's just like a badass divorce
like she's just a gangster and i've
looked she's so good makes you want to
get divorced she's like a she's like a
celebrity to me
like when i first came she loved divorce
[Laughter]
you're like rooting for when i no when i
moved to l.a
all you hear is like laura wasser laura
wasser laura
like she's like a legend she is a
an enigmatic sort of like um
i don't know she's just i've just i've
been obsessed with her for a very long
time
and i was nervous in the beginning and
then i think i feel like i it's actually
going to divorce you listen i
i i was scared of her she's very
intimidated i was very it's very rare
that i'm like you'd leave the interview
she'd own the house
i know i'm just like anyway so i'll head
out let me know when
yeah totally she by the way the
interview is so funny because
i keep people long because i ramble and
she was like um i have to go
like she literally got up and left she
said i have three lives to end
okay well then she literally was like
it's just 6 30 i got to comb through six
prenup
she walked she walked off camera as we
were recording i could not keep her
she's like no bitch when i say
something's gonna happen it happens
time is money it was amazing like i'm in
awe of her she's i don't know what you
do here with this bubble gum hair i know
i'm like i found what we're doing around
here i know she was like a very serious
professional adult guest and i was like
when you first contacted her she was
like divorced and i'm like don't write
elephants and she's like i'm out of here
that was what it was yeah she you sent
her that dm you're like hey can i have
you and she's like do you have a divorce
i know i'm just getting that vibe she's
950 an hour
does she win a lot yes all right
i love you guys enjoy love you love you
love you
i'm fully obsessed with you do you
remember the first time i called you
i i i had a manic break
i dm'd you yes would i and because i'm
not really good at that
i didn't see it for like a month
and you're like oh she probably needs a
divorce no
i'm waiting for this call i think you
might have written i'm obsessed with you
so i didn't think you needed a divorce
like i'm
but i don't think you know this
but as a woman a holman
in hollywood like laura wasser is like a
you're like a god oh my god to
women uh who make money
you're like i remember thinking in my
20s being like
i want to be so successful that one day
laura wasser is going to represent me
in my divorce you did not think that
anymore i i truly
i'm not even joking okay like i want to
be i think that's a good goal
i want to be so successful that laura
wasser's my lawyer
okay it's like the rolls-royce it's like
getting a rolls-royce or getting a house
in malibu or whatever it is it's kind of
like getting a like you know you made it
gold-plated coffin or something if you
think about it it's like a rather
dubious honor but i do
appreciate that very much like you've
been
this enigmatic um
person to me for a long time like
looming in my life
as someone also who i come from a lot of
divorce
um you know i made a tv show
about literally a girl that didn't want
to get married
i saw it really oh i used to watch that
show really
yeah and good show you're very funny i'm
very fraught
on the concept of marriage because i
grew up with a very acrimonious
marriage um and so talking to you is
like
i don't even know where to start
and you're gorgeous and it's frustrating
i'm sorry
well thank you um i yeah i can
understand why marriage
would be
complicated and again that's one of the
things that i really would like to
change
not so much about marriage but about the
idea of a marriage
not necessarily being forever and so
i've been doing this now for
25 26 years my dad
was and is a family law attorney so i
kind of grew up with it i grew up here
in southern california i would go to
a bar mitzvah or sweet 16 and often the
mom would go
oh you're a wasser you're at the shady
table because your dad represented my
husband or whatever
so i so i and it's amazing to me
that in 2021 we still approach
marriage and for that matter of divorce
in these super
old outdated
lame ways and so i'm trying to change
that a little bit again i
by by having conversations and
communication
and and even prenups prior to marriage
and then if it doesn't work out having a
better
co-parent than you did a spouse by being
able to like work through it that to me
is like that's my
life's work right there so what
is what is your definition of love
what is my dad like can like i have so
many questions for you
um like the first one like
do you feel like
love is real 100
100 love is real but love is like so
vast i mean i love my kids
yeah i love my best friend you know i i
love
my housekeeper i think probably more
than any of the aforementioned people
because she's like been with us through
this pandemic through thick and thin
but the idea of like romantic love and
partnership
marriage long-term you know relationship
love
i think that factors into it a certain
amount
everyone's going to say oh laura you're
you're you know you're so
jaded or but it's a contract we each
bring something to the table
and we and if that changes what one of
us is bringing for example
the trophy wife super hot super fun
super sexy mary's super wealthy
super sophisticated super wise maybe a
little paternal
and then it changes he loses her money
she loses her look something changes
you have to reevaluate what that
relationship is going to be because we
know why we got into it
if there was love underlying that great
but these things have to be addressed
and i think that is the case in every
relationship
why why am i scared to get married
because of everything that you know
about it because you're scared to be
you're scared of failure um so if i
get married that's it i don't that's
married forever
then i'm a failure that's really the key
to it
is that when you get married there's
this
i have this emotional perfectionism of
everything has to be perfect has to be
right measure twice cut once like i have
so
i feel like i've whether it's socially
constructed or
who cares biological i have this thing
that's like if you're not
married you're just not an adult
well that's another thing a marriage is
a symbol of getting older
moving on i mean look i got married once
i was 25 years old
it was gorgeous we were both gorgeous
that's the time of your hotel yeah i
mean i'll never i've never gotten
married again because
i'll never be able to beat those
photographs well now we have
a filter yes everybody should get
married once for sure i mean i do think
it's like
beautiful and fun and it's your day or
whatever that being said
there's no shame in my opinion
to a marriage coming to an end yeah
you're entering into a contract right
okay
i mean a real contract not you know
what's hot and you're rich
but but a real contract which is in
every state the laws are different so in
this state in california
the minute you get married every dollar
your
you earn every painting you paint every
sculpture you sculpt every screenplay
you write
is now owned half by the other person so
so let me just
walk through that the the psychology
because i was thinking about this last
night i couldn't sleep
i was thinking about you and i was like
okay so
i do feel like the person the
my the person i'm currently with he does
do so much for me you know
like he's like he does a bunch of stuff
yes i can't get the script done without
him
feeding the dogs like but do i need to
if we're married and we get divorced do
i need to pay you for that all of a
sudden you're my employee
right well it gets better than that
because it's not just that he would own
half of that screenplay but then also if
he was not the breadwinner he don't have
the screenplay and you'd be paying him
spousal support
and if you had kids and even if he was
not necessarily the stay-home parent but
he just happened to be the parent who
stayed home but he wasn't the one making
the doctor's appointments or the school
you know conference yeah
all that you're gonna pay him child
support i mean
so and if you get married and you're not
aware of that well then in this day and
age in my opinion you're a fool
like find out what the fucking law is in
your state yeah
before you get married okay you're
entering and these people that are
getting married and they're having the
florist and they're having the band and
they're having you know the
the cake and the dress all of those are
contracts and people stress about those
contracts they read the fine print what
if somebody dies in a plane crash do i
still have to pay for the florist
whatever
but your the marriage contract is the
biggest contract and they don't even
know what it is they come to me 10 years
later and go
well of course i will get the house
because i'm the mom
and i'm like what are you talking about
he bought that house before you guys got
married
so if someone's 25 years old and they're
about to get married
what state should they get married in
first of all it depends whether they
make money or not
moved to texas nashville um
but like if you're 25 and you're like
i want to get married well it's not
where you get married it's where you
live
before you live you can't fly to
nashville get married and then come back
and live in california for 10 years and
then go i'm getting divorced
you know you it's where you live it's
where you reside and we actually have
cases
because we represent at my firm a lot of
wealthy people where they live part of
the time here and part of the time in
australia and part of the time
in you know new york and there's
different laws so then we start looking
at people's licenses and where their
kids are enrolled in school i mean
there's all kinds of things that
determine jurisdiction
by the way if you want to be a
basketball baby mama
you want to be having that baby in
california you
write because we have very high child
support guidelines here
right so can i just ask you just on a
personal level because i've been
i'm so obsessed with you as a person
yes you're so like it's so i'm so scared
of you i'm
still yes yes yes i'm scared of you and
terry showed me the whole house this is
like my nightmare
is like to have a super smart gorgeous
lawyer who like knows
you know um what's what in terms of like
emotionally like are you able to really
delineate
like this is my job and this is this is
what i think but i'm going to do my job
like are you able to
separate church and state yes how are
you able to do that
well first of all i'm in a great
position that i don't have to take
clients that i don't like
so you know and if i have somebody
that's sitting across from me that i
really dislike or i find them to be very
unrealistic
or entitled i don't have to take their
case i can send them to one of my very
competent colleagues and
off you go so that's one thing and the
other thing is the one thing somebody
actually asked me i did an interview for
which is this is really exciting not as
exciting as the whitney cummings podcast
for the wall street journal the other
day and there was that my monday morning
and she said
what's the one thing that you've learned
doing your job after all these years and
the one thing that i've learned and this
is how i kind of do
delineate or at least live with it is
don't judge don't judge it's so easy to
judge especially living where we live
and doing what we do but like
you can't you never know what's going on
in somebody else's
situation it's so hard to empathize
um what would you say is like the
main pandemic aside main
reason people break up lack of
communication
we grow apart and we don't talk about it
while it's happening and so what happens
is you have resentments you have secrets
you have you know petty things
and then maybe you go fuck somebody else
or then you develop a gambling or a drug
problem or you start doing
online you know porn or whatever and
you're hiding it because it's verboten
because it feels good
that this online porn cheating no i
don't think so
no i don't think so at all doesn't does
that count like i don't even know what
the rules are if it counts because
california and in fact most states in
the us are no fault so none of it counts
you can what does that mean no fault
statement no fault state means if you're
having an affair
you don't get less money or have to pay
more money makes no difference
because the burden of proof is just so
high
that we changed that we were one of the
first states to change that i think
back in the late 60s early 70s and even
like now
i think you can opt in in some states
like louisiana you can say oh i want to
have fault let me tell you something
because if i find out he's cheating on
me i want to be able to get more
but in most states it's just no fault no
fault i just don't want to hear he did
this and she did this it doesn't matter
a no fault state so that's what that
means
yes that it means
we're going to leave my morals at the
door correct
i mean obviously domestic violence yeah
and if there's a drug problem and
there's kids involved
you know those things matter so
sometimes there's a little fault when it
comes into
custody because we don't want somebody
that's doing drugs or beating
children or burning them with cigarettes
something like that but besides that no
fault we don't care who you slept with
we don't care
that you went to strip clubs we don't
care about online porn
so i read this book um by elizabeth
gilbert
called committed um uh you pray love was
not like my
like thing but uh
committed she went all around the world
and she talked about what commitment
and marriage meant in every culture and
in western culture it was very much like
like a business and keeping land in the
family and
and such like what do you think
legally like marriage wise is antiquated
like what should go legally are there
any laws where you're just like this is
a ridiculously antiquated law
that makes no sense anymore
yeah i think well first of all here's my
biggest pet peeve and i don't know if
it's antiquated but it certainly doesn't
work for me i don't understand
why filings in family law matters are
public
i mean do you know what a bone in my
throat tmz is
in every case yeah so why why is that
you ask harvey levin and he'll say well
it keeps judges honest and first
amendment and people
you know shouldn't be able to keep
things private why not it's your private
life
whether you're rich and famous or you're
joe schmo why does that have to be out
there for everybody to see
hmm interesting okay so is that a
california large
it's in almost all states in other
states you can kind of withhold names so
it's harder for them to get it but these
are supposed to be public filings also
why does people magazine need to know
how much money i'm getting from my
spouse each month or
how much my land is worth in pacoima why
are
why are we so obsessed with breakups
it's
schadenfreude famous people breakups i
mean you know your cousin's
you know whatever gets divorced who
cares but if a famous
rich beautiful person gets divorced we
want to know about it and then
like you know it's funny because when
people move in together
i'm like it's you're basically married
right that's what they say you're
basically it's going to be as hard
emotionally
right so why what's the difference
between uh signing the contract and not
the money yup the laws yup well that's
why i never got married again when i was
25 i had no money but there was nothing
to divide
i put credit card debt a jeep wrangler
and a pit bull
whoops i got them all credit card debts
also my tinder bio
frankly um
what would you say to someone who's 25
and wants to get married
right now again depending on the person
but probably i think you're probably
young give it some time
what's the rush why are you getting
married move in together right
have sex i mean we were too young there
was no question about that and i think
my parents knew that when they walked me
down the aisle but they were like
they've always been like do your thing i
went to live in australia for a year do
your thing
i went to marry this guy from madrid
spain do your thing
and you know it turned out okay so
i would also probably say make sure that
you're in some kind of couples
counseling
even at 25 even when things are good
because i think you can then develop the
tools
necessary to talk through and
communicate through the hard times and
there's gonna be hard times
but it's also i think you know it's
interesting because
when i think about getting married young
i'm just like i'm if i had married the
person that i
was with when i was 25 like i was a
totally different person
right 10 years later by that you know so
it's like finding the person that will
evolve
with you right which how can you really
know how will you know
who that person is giving you have the
tools to kind of communicate you can
even say we're not evolving together
what are we doing about this and either
go our separate ways also
in this town there's a lot of really
savvy 25 year olds frankly especially
the entertainment industry that have
millions of dollars they've already been
around whatever right
so i wouldn't say the same thing to
every 25 year old yeah
but yes yeah with time comes experience
and so you do change
what are the advantages of being married
like legally
like because there are times when like
you know my dad had a stroke
uh both my parents had strokes 10 years
ago and it's like
there's a family family like there's a
there's right there's a next of kin
thing at hospitals which
most of the time you can work around now
um especially if you you
can be a domestic partner in this state
even if you're not married so that you
have so
and again that's what that's what the
state came up with early on before we
allowed same-sex marriages and some
people have just decided to still do
that
there's tax advantages to being married
um and what is that what is that i don't
know what it is that a government that
like
is that everything so is that like a yes
antiquated
religious if you are married you are
better that's why we get dependency
deductions for kids
it's like it's a total that's scammy
yeah yeah
but how does it benefit the government
if we're married i mean i don't even get
i don't even understand like it it is an
institutionally way to
um not that i'm getting married guys
just so you know i will be getting
married and laura will be my lawyer i'm
doing the preen
i will start drafting i have a whole
person but he's out there
it's a soccer player sperm is in spain
it's on ice right now
my baby daddy there's no huge
financial benefit conferred upon you by
the government by being married there
are some tax breaks
and by the way just for your listeners
anything that you do
inherit even when you're married in
california that's your separate property
so you don't have to share
that with your spouse why don't they
teach this in schools
isn't that crazy so anything you bring
to the marriage like your futon from
college that stays yours
it's yours yeah your bank accounts and
stuff that you brought into the marriage
including your debt student debt you
that's all separate anything you inherit
at any time
or any gifts so we have a lot of clients
who are like oh well the studio gave me
this
you know rolls royce and i that's mine
and that's a gift to me
my dad always being a family law
attorney whenever he would go to
somebody's wedding like the wedding of
one of his friend's kids
he'd write the check the gift to the one
person that he was friends with the
parents of
so that if they got divorced they could
be like this is my second property from
dennis monster
i was like really that's the wedding
guest you are
they already hate us because we're
divorce lawyers at the wedding
we are talking to a very expensive
lawyer right now on this podcast
uh who very few people can afford
but you can talk to a therapist
regularly yes
with better help and worldwide have it
be affordable
yeah you can do it from the convenience
and the comfort we're gonna stare at
each other the whole time like this yeah
i don't know why you can do it why are
you looking at me
to prove i don't need to look anywhere
else you can do this from the
convenience and the comfort of wherever
you are
you're being a crazy you can do it
whenever you need it however
however you long why are you looking at
me better hope is there to help you look
at the
copy better help can really help you
it's online
therapy not counseling not counseling
therapy professional therapy online
covid safe it's more affordable than
traditional online
accounts offline counseling excuse me
this is online better
better help help me help you let better
help
help you visit betterhelp.com whitney
that's better help and join the over 1
million people taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all
50 states can you name them all no
special offer for good for you listeners
get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
whitney
listen a big plot hole in our friendship
that you won't bring me food
i've never been to your where you live
thank god you've never invited me so and
i won't
because um so but you don't bring me
food so i have to use doordash for that
um jordan is great well here's what i'm
going to do i want to go to your place
and we're going to do a mukbang with
doordash
uh we're going to order a bunch of
doordash and do a mukbang in your
at your place there's not room for both
of us
especially not me you and the food i
mean i know i don't i
don't i do suck the air out of every
room i'm in
uh there won't be any oxygen for you but
there will be physical space
i don't know um but yes doordash
is doordash will bring your favorite
restaurants right to you
easy simple you can pick on there you go
right on there there's
over 300 000 partners in the u.s puerto
rico canada and australia
doordash is like it's what are we doing
you can support local
neighborhood go-to's or you can do big
chain restaurants you want chipotle
they'll bring it to you this has saved
my
it's i'm in a good relationship right
now and i truly think it's because
we've heard i think it's because the
door-to-door the biggest
fights i've been in are like what are we
gonna eat what are we going to order we
have to drive to the restaurant why do
we have to drive to this restaurant
well you pick it up this does sound like
a good relationship what
you're in such a good relationship you
brought a divorce attorney on that is
wild
how lucky can one be she's a star
i'm just saying like i this this will
help you relate door dash just let
someone else
handle it you want that pop-up chicken
sandwich they'll bring it to you
self-care
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code whitney2021 that's 25
off up to 10 value and zero delivery
fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store
and enter codewhitney2021 don't forget
that's code whitney
2021 for 25 percent off your first order
with doordash
subject to change terms apply
i just feel like there's something so
hot
about like you know i was engaged
talking through the prenup was a very
bonding experience
like if you i found myself not being
able to bring it up
like if you can't bring up that
conversation you probably shouldn't get
married
whether you signed it or not exactly if
you can't have the conversation i say
that all the time to people and they're
like but it's so unromantic and it's so
and i'm like it's usually that's what
guys usually say to me they're
how do how do i ask her laura how do i
sit down there i said well
if you guys are drinkers i would have a
bottle of wine and i would say you know
blame it on
someone else even if you don't have a
lot of i think people think prenups are
for like
only the kardashians no like this is for
moving forward it involves kids it
involves finance involve kids
dozens kids won't be interested explain
to prenup prenup will have will
involve setting forth how you want to
treat your property and your earnings
after marriage
it can involve child custody can't
involve child support because you don't
know what you're going to be making and
you can't contract for that because
that's not
your right that's the kids right we're
not talking about kids in a prenup
but you can talk about anything i make i
want to keep as my separate property
right i've been a i've been a comedian
and an
actor for several years and i've made
who i am and i don't think that just
because i go now make another show
he should be entitled to half of it
right off the bat that doesn't make
sense but
i'm willing to put 50 of everything i
make
into a joint account so that 50 of
everything i make can be kind of the
things we grow and move from
i'm willing to gift a portion of the
house i own every year to him that we
stay together
and you can also put testamentary things
was that the word you were thinking of
definitely not i definitely did not know
that word if if you're marrying someone
that's a lot older or younger and one
person might die first you can put in
there that because you can always change
your will
but you can't change your prenup so you
got the guy
whoa whoa
you can't change your prenup after
you've you you can if you both agree
but let's say the guy has a will and the
will says i'm going to give everything
to my lovely wife
she's been so wonderful for 35 years and
then in like a year you know the last
year he
maybe falls ill he's in the hospital
he's got this super hot poisonous tina
caretaker and all of a sudden at the
last minute on his own he gives
everything to her
okay you can do that but if you write a
prenup that says no matter what happens
i'm giving at least 25 to my lovely wife
that can't be changed yes or unless the
wife came in does that happen a lot like
at the buzzer death bed
what yeah people get nuts
so this is what's so fascinating to me
is like you're an
incredibly like your job is to be
incredibly factual
literal with people that are incredibly
emotional
yes and again it's it what's interesting
to me and why i've been doing it for so
long is it's
super interesting so you get like
bankers and financial
geniuses and then you get actors and
then you get
football players and then you get rock
stars all these people that you think
are like
invincible unstoppable have everything
in the world
and then they're just like vulnerable
and cuddles like help me help me know
everything about them i know how much
pubic hair they have
i don't need to but they need to tell me
this information i know
we're crying and they're snot and like
in the middle of the night
and then it's over and i never see them
again like i'm at a restaurant and i
have like i get laid across the room
like
hey yeah which is fine because like i
learned early on like you i represent
the worst time of their life and the
most they can do is be like dude
she got me out of it she's awesome how
much of your job is like
emotionally placating people and how
much
a lot a lot but also imagine
most of my clients are in therapy
therapists are like even the really good
ones three or four hundred dollars an
hour
crazy i'm 9.50 and i'm a hot mess you're
9.50 an
hour i wasn't married this is gonna be a
short podcast guys
i normally go four hours it took me an
hour to get it
i was like where's woodland hills i
don't understand i grew up in a thousand
dollars just to get her here
that's how expensive laura wasser is
incredible
so yeah i mean there's there's there's a
lot of the emotional but there's also if
you're a good family law attorney you
can draw the line and be like look
i'm not your friend we're not going to
have this this is the line together and
talk about your next boyfriend
that is for your friends or your mom or
your sister or your therapist
i can apply the facts of your situation
and i can also tell you hey i've been
doing this for 25 years
this too shall fucking pass we're gonna
get you through this you will be okay
what's the biggest mistake you see
people consistently make over and over
again when they come into your office
thinking with their you know not making
business decisions this is a business
decision that you're making getting
married is a business decision as is
getting divorced
wow yes it is because you can love
someone
forever but you can't always be married
to them forever that's right
and love goes in and out lust goes in
and out yes like goes in and out like
i was like i will always love you i do
not like you
right now it's like the the people that
i follow on instagram the people i love
the most sometimes i gotta mute
yeah for some you know sometimes i had
to mute you you know and
um do you ever feel have people come
into your office that you're like this
is premature
yeah you're this is irrational yes you
should stay in this
yes and i have seen people do you feel
that people are too like have you
noticed over your
uh uh career people being too quick to
get divorced
these days no
here's why yeah because it's very
expensive to hire me
yeah not too quick however i i think you
know i have an online divorce website
yes
we will have a lot of people you're
making it too easy to get divorced
we will have are you why the divorce
rate is so high
no but that has really skyrocketed over
the pandemic whereas our firm is pretty
much we're always busy it's always
consistent we don't have more calls i
think
actually people have gotten closer
during the pandemic and reestablished
family values and how it works and
i've seen a lot of families where
dad might be the breadwinner and mom
might be the stay-home mom
and yet dad's now doing cooking a couple
nights a week and
dad might be more you know i love that
remote learning with the kids
the pandemic has been so funny to me
because um
all my guy friends have called me and
it's made them realize how much
their wives do yes like
they're home all day i'm home all day
with the kid and i'm cooking i have to
make breakfast lunch and dinner it's
like yeah
women have been doing this all this time
yep
just fyi the pandemic like like
all my guy friends like my wife is like
a superhero she's done this every day
the working moms that were already
working and now i mean
we do that both because when i say like
stay home parent
for whatever reason a lot of the times
the dads are like well where's the nanny
yeah like what i'm the nanny
yeah i remember i'm uh uh who's i was
talking to a friend of mine
and the dad uh said something about
their kid and was like oh well we need
to get someone to
um i i don't have time to babysit the
kid and she goes it's not babysitting
you're
it's your kid it doesn't it's not
babysitting it's called parenting
right and you're not doing me any favors
yeah no no you don't get points for that
yeah what i'm saying like parenting is i
think that has changed a bit
during this thing i wonder what will
happen afterwards
do you feel like more people are
breaking up
because the pandemic or people are
hunkering down
you know what beginning i was saying i
think people were breaking up i think
the prospect of doing this
now i think the ones that have stayed
have hunkered down i mean we'll see i
think it's an interesting time it's an
interesting reevaluation of your
relationship i mean
my i have different relationships with
my friends than i used to have so true
so true i it really is like are you
worth dying for
yeah those are the friends i talk to i'm
like even are you worth being
uncomfortable for yeah
i mean i don't yeah i don't like you
enough to sit six feet away in the cold
i mean
i i like you but i don't want to hang
out like huh
like i i don't like you enough to listen
to you through a mask
right right like you're not entertaining
enough
to like have to do this it's true and
and it makes you think and or
or even going out i mean we couldn't for
a while now we can't so like
you know i used to go out three or four
nights a week yeah i go out like one
night a week and i'm still like
god that telenovela and netflix i'm
really into it is anna gonna have the
baby or not
do you um get annoyed like yes i was
thinking
and i hate asking this but i we like to
sort of um overthink
and uh uh what's the word over analyze
and get granular in this podcast about
you know as a
woman in a male dominated business is
that fair to say
that law is male-dominated yeah it's
requires being a performer it requires
being
outspoken it requires being aggressive
it requires being right
it requires being unapologetic and
it's my dream is to be a lawyer like i
wish i was a lawyer my dad was lawyer
that's what i wish i was the reason i
love fighting with boyfriends and having
bad relationships is because i like get
to be an imaginary court of law
i like i love i love fighting i love
it's
in my blood right i'm so good at it
and i love doing it and i feel like
law is my calling um but stand up became
my
sort of thing right stand up is like i
like to think of
myself as like a lawyer when i do stand
up it's like here's my point
that let me defend myself and then you
defend yourself right
i'm going to make a point that is
absolutely ridiculous
i'm going to convince you i'm right and
then you're going to laugh
and tell me that's kind of what it is
you're sort of on the stand right that's
that to me is what stand up is like um
so
i'm basically a lawyer um but that's how
i like
i mean i'm basically a stand-up comedian
no you're not you're too sane you're way
too sane and pulled together yeah
my question is basically like
being a woman what does it like mean
has it helped has it hurt do you feel
like you've had to
i don't think it's hurt and you know i
don't i also don't think first of all in
family law these days it is
almost as it's almost more women than it
is men great whatever
great great and when i speak with young
women at law schools
what i will often say is you don't have
to yell
you don't i mean sometimes if you're at
a boardroom conference or if you're
in a in on this you know you're
questioning a witness
you can just speak quietly you don't
have to overpower you don't have to bang
the table that works for some people
yep it probably won't work for you
you'll seem like you're shrieking
be you you don't have to cuss like a
sailor but if you do it's okay
you be you and you find what works for
you
i never liked wearing suits i'm not a
jacket kind of a girl
when i started practicing law the senior
partner at my firm basically said like
we don't wear pants at this firm which i
was fine with like the women
you have to wear skirts i mean this was
like the 90s and i was cool with that
because i didn't like wearing pant suits
i didn't feel feminine i didn't
but i do have a big tattoo on my ankle
and he was like
we're going to be covering that up
what's the tattoo of the star
you know the stars oh dr
but you know this was in the this is in
the wait wait no i don't what
star bellied sneetches dr seuss the
story look it up
okay kind of like an equality story so
the star-bellied snitches
had had stars on their bellies and they
were like the elite
and the ones who didn't have stars were
like the peasants but then a guy came
and he had a machine and you could go
through the machine you could get a star
on your stomach
so then everybody had the stars but then
the elites were like well fuck that shit
and then the same guy who's making a
mint from these sneetches he comes and
he takes the
things off so now the elite were the
non-star bellied sneetches
and they kept going and they kept going
and so they went so much that nobody
could tell who was who and the moral of
the story is
we're all the same and so you have one
of these is it green
it's like turquoise my parents were like
you do you like they never cared
and were jewish like it was like oh you
can't be buried in a jewish cemetery and
then my mom got one
we talk a lot on the show about red
flags what would you say would be like
top red flags like i i feel like we go
on dates
at this point and just look for proof
to prove ourselves right of the person
we invented in our heads
right that's how i go on dates i'm like
i'm gonna just look for all the evidence
that you're the person i made up
and i'm gonna ignore all the red flags
you know what i mean just sort of like
oh
he doesn't have a car because he has a
dui no that's so great it's so much
better for the environment
thank you so much oh my god he's green
he rides a bike
he's a dui bitch like right how i am
able to just
totally um uh paint red flags
white yeah that will change i think
as i used to get older or stay single
for a little bit longer
yeah i think it's in your gut i think
it's like for me there's all these rules
people like
how how do i know if i'm in a bad
relationship or not don't look at him or
her
look at you how do you feel when you're
with them right right it's not about
them forget about them
how do you how are you behaving are you
being inauthentic are you performing are
you finding
do you wake up in the morning and put on
makeup and then get back in bed and
pretend
that you're not wearing you know like
are you finding yourself performing
pretending
mothering micromanaging martyring like
are
you exhausted yeah that's the other
thing
that's my my last relationship i was
exhausted like
again it wasn't because i was being
inauthentic it was just it was
exhausting to be in that relationship
and you know then you get to the point
of well what are you going to do about
it
also you have to be in a point when you
get into a relationship
where you're not looking for what kind
of car
he drives or what kind of job he has or
how is he going to make you feel you
already feel
great yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what do
you add to the equation
it's like what is the value added here
that is going to make things better for
me and by the way
you can look the same thing about me who
are you
do you feel good with about who you are
and how can i add value to you
and that's what it's about but it's not
easy and look we nobody wants to be
alone
and it's scary and it feels so good to
be in the beginning stages of love
i think a therapist once told me that
like the first however many months of a
relationship that bliss that's like
triggered in your head whatever that
oxytocin is the same thing that mothers
have when they look at their newborn yup
mm-hmm it's like a it's like a seven
week old with the baby
yes they'll love her it's like it's it's
a um
uh almost like delusional
like it the idea is to anesthetize yeah
i mean because the oxytocin is released
in the brain when you hold the baby
literally we're programmed to forget
about the pain from childbirth and the
horror
right it's a way to like trick us into
procreating again
forgetting all the horror that just
happened it's a way to like
gasp that horrible for childbirth
i had two c-sections it just did you
just schedule you just schedule them
both either way i grow them must be
breached so the first one i was like oh
no
i'm having a vaginal birth that is
happening and we did everything that we
burned mugwort by my toe and we turned
him which was really
painful and whatever and then he just
turned right back so my my gynecologist
scheduled a c-section but he didn't tell
me but he knew i was gonna need it and
then cedars called and was like hey
we're just calling back and i was like
oh no
i called him and i was like what the
hell and he said look you're gonna have
a c-section if you want to keep telling
yourself you're not but i didn't want
you to lose the date because i didn't
want your water to break so
and then i eventually just i went with
it and then my second one
also grew that way and i was like i
already got the scar get in there
what is the what is the shame around
c-section
i don't think it's the same anymore
first of all they're way safer for the
baby
why are we why i i would schedule the
c-section the second i find out i'm
pregnant i will schedule the c-section
yeah i mean i got a blow-dry the night
well yeah
i'm just saying why is there they cut me
open why do we have to
what are what is the pride and let's do
it the way they did it 300 years ago
don't take any drugs and by the way
let's do it at home like let's make it
as uncomfortable because let's get in a
cast
why don't you why are we trying to make
this as painful as possible what's the
no one gives you a check at the end it's
like you suffered the most
here's your trophy speak with women who
have done water births or done home
births or done even just natural they're
very
they feel very good about it i mean
that's another thing you're having a
baby you better not i'm sure when i mean
when i make bad choices i stand by them
afterwards because i have to prove
myself
you know what i mean like i i'm not
saying it's a bad decision i'm not
anti-home birth i'm just saying like
why make it more difficult like i i just
feel like science
works i like science factors i mean for
me
he said like look if it's going if
you're going to have
a labor that is going to involve having
to pull the baby out backwards which the
umbilical cord crap around his neck is
dangerous
dangerous why are why are i want to play
golf on that day can you please bear
with me and i was like okay
dude i get it i dated a pediatric
anesthesiologist sometimes i make good
choices
um and uh he yeah he was like the number
one
um this is really dark the number one
sort of trauma he saw in the er were
babies coming in from home birth
that had the umbilical cord wrapped
around or something you know so it's i
it interests me when you know this sort
of um
as humans as we evolve we often want to
go back to the analog
a lot of the times you know what i mean
let's talk about one more thing though
how about the pooing on the table
the shitting yeah well yeah no my
brother
that all he had to say i i said you had
me it should
i you're gonna be shitting in front of
you well that's why i always still shit
on your baby
like i don't want to have a prenup and
i'm like well listen and it's so
unromantic i'm like guess what
it's unromantic when he's standing there
they're like come on baby like a big
shit comes out so why don't we get
through the prenup first
and then we can move on to that on
romantic thank you that's awesome
yeah it's over easy
i mean jesus so wait
so so that is was your uh were your
partners in the room when you gave birth
yeah
one of them almost fainted the second
one baby daddy too
he was really nervous but the second one
i had what would happen to me with jack
my second one is whenever i would lean
back
the vena cava which is i guess the vein
that goes to the heart he'd
he'd knock into it and so i would like
pass out
so when i laid back for them to cut me
open
i didn't pass out but the the blood
wasn't going to the baby so they kind of
had to get in there a little bit more
quickly than they thought which then
led miner to be extremely he got really
upset but then he was okay everyone
everyone was just watching you just get
stabbed to death
look dr certain's amazing it'd be
weirder
if he didn't pass out we were if he was
like yeah this is awesome well he's
getting a boat
[Laughter]
let me do it can i do it again now
there's nothing in there
you know what give me the knife i have
some ideas
i have officially run out of things to
watch
i've watched everything in the pandemic
i've watched it all
i've watched everything so what are you
doing now moving on to
literally video games i'm a i'm a gamer
now oh
are you sure i am are you trying to
twitch i'm going to get a chair i want
to get a gamer chair
you're going to get a game or try to
play best fiends now well no messages
for everyone how dare you
my favorite game was fruit ninja it was
like a it's like a
game you can like play on your phone
well yeah i was super into fruit ninja
and my new obsession is best fiends we
got there
i know i'm just saying look
i don't just say ads here's one thing i
like a lot
and here's another i just want you to
i'm making it organic
i just i do actually use gay i'm telling
you the truth
about my experience with this product
unlike a lot of these podcast hosts that
just
read it with no feeling listen
it is a really fun it's a casual puzzle
game it's really great i sometimes get
so into it that i don't answer phone
calls i
love it i will ignore phone calls it's
just soothing there's something so
soothing
it's like it's not news it's not
triggering it's not someone yelling at
me on twitter it's not like
negative it's not political it's like
it's super fun it's super engaging and
you can it's it's free to download which
is amazing it has over 100 million
downloads by the way
well i mean everyone knows about this
game if you guys don't have it i don't
know what's going on well if you don't
have it that's why they pay this for
this so listen up dude it's bet honestly
this is best fiends like playing this
game it has stopped me from like
texting x's it's stopped me from making
a lot of bad decisions
it's a good thing to it's like my fidget
spinner it's like when i'm anxious
and i'm about to do a make a bad choice
i'll like go on and just like play it
and i'll like and like
it's a healthy escape it's yes that's
what it is and the characters
adorable um you can level them up they
change
they're so cute i mean like little come
on bugs and they're fighting slugs
bugs find slugs stop it it is a good
game you should download it download
best fiends
free today on the apple app store or
google play that's
friends without the r best
[Applause]
and so you're with someone but not
married no i'm not with anyone right now
oh got it right would you ever get
married again
i mean never say never but nobody's ever
given i mean i've had
since my marriage i've had i'd say four
significant
long-term relationships two with the
fathers of my kids
we never thought of any reasons why we
should have gotten hugely successful i
mean it's like i'm
i'm get married i'm sure i will but i
just i feel like we
look at a if you're with someone for six
years and break up that is a huge
success
yeah most marriages don't last that long
yeah right that's
if that's how i felt and it was they
were it was actually seven years last
one
great seven years an amazing
relationship don't regret
almost anything else yeah and like
that's
but but yeah that's when i think about
people that are married for 25
30 years and if they say i haven't
really been happy for the last 10 i'm
like
what do you feel like in the
uh successful relationships you've seen
there's been a common denominator
yeah communication yeah and
consideration like really
communicating but not just in a
constantly fighting way yes
communicating doesn't so you feel and
and i'm going to make considerations for
those
feelings and yeah communicating like the
i think the footnote on that is like
say what you mean me what you say don't
say it mean communicating doesn't mean
you need to fucking do this
right communicating doesn't mean who the
fuck are you texting that's not
communication that's
shaming someone you know what i mean
it's like connecting
not going to the problem for the
solution and going like here's my
problem here's the solution do you think
you could do you think you can provide
that or not
you know like it's the common
denominator and and work it's hard
it's hard to stay in a long relationship
and so what does that mean relationship
tapes work i bump on that
because i have many jobs okay i know but
you got to make time for the
relationship i don't know if you've ever
been in a relationship where your
significant other has said i feel like
i'm not getting your time i feel like
you have many jobs and i get that
but then i want to be one of the people
that you devote time to and look with me
i have
two kids they have two dads my family's
all here in la i have
i have two jobs at least because i've
got the podcast i mean the
website and and i used to do a podcast
too and i've got the firm
so yeah there's a lot of work you have
to make time for the other person and
even
if you don't have as many jobs but
you've got kids and you focus on your
kids all the time and you love your kids
so much and you want your kids yeah
maybe one of your kids has some issues
or whatever you have to make time for
your significant other and when you make
the time the time isn't
hi no no come on it's date night it's
really
cutting out the time so that you can
unwind before you get into date night
not like it's just like climb on it has
to be like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
and that's hard
that's hard to do you got to put on the
ball gag what
exactly um that's interesting
is a very helpful tip for making sure
that you don't say
things that you would otherwise be
learning i actually
wrong i actually i actually love a ball
gag
i don't know i'm just saying like i've
seen them and i'm like
that i actually might need that because
in during sex i do
sometimes i do get the the the like
giggles
well you can still giggle through a ball
it's just like just saying that's not
how we do you might have to do something
a little bit like a whole face
something i haven't worn one in a while
but it sometimes like because i feel
like guys now they'll like try out some
weird thing they saw in porn
and it's like it always is just like oh
jesus like
guys are trying to fish hook now they're
like guys are like just doing things
it's fish hooking it's when you grab
take is this on a mouth or on another
organ
what is it what is what is that god i've
been out of the game for too long
when you take what you do that to a
vaginal opening or is it on a mouth
where do you do that whitney
what's happening here we gotta get you
on bumble
it's no it's like a thing is it my face
okay
just tell me don't look at me and tell
me what it is
it's guys will take like you lie the
mouth like this
and and then what and then to funk you i
guess
in the mouth why are they doing that
when they're fucking you
this may only happen to you i think you
had this happen to you and then he was
like haven't you heard of it fish
hooking everyone
but he just didn't want you to be
laughing i gotta stop dating fishermen
i don't think that's a real thing i
think you got catfished
by a fish hooker and now you're trying
to play it out
and i'm gonna be like in the bedroom
next week going like how about we do the
fish hook
maybe it's just me i i don't know if
it's porn or if it's my personality
it's porn it's a little is it porn or
they're trying to kill me it's also the
times that we're in right now
people we are so um desensitized
to any violence to any anything that
people are like doing what the
especially kids i mean i haven't had
sex with very many children lately but i
do feel like teenagers
they are learning about sex remember we
had like the magazines and we'd find
them and
you know my dad used to go to this
barber and when i would go to the barber
with him i'd see the dirty magazines and
i was like oh my god you know
even i was like a little girl i was like
kind of like looking at these ladies
with big boobs and whatever and
why do i feel this way whatever but but
kids that's not how they're learning now
they're like having like they're
watching hardcore porn with slapping
and choking and evidently fish hooking
and now that's what they're learn that's
how they think it's supposed to be
yes and there's a there's a great ted
talk by gail dines about this
um about what porn is doing uh to kids
brains
uh there's also an amazing uh joke by a
comedian named dan mintz
where he it's he's like a very dry dry
one-liner type
uh uh comedian i think he writes on big
mouth now or something but um
he goes uh you know when i was uh
technology has totally changed the way
that i
you know jerk off and in sex you know
because it used to be when i was a kid
you'd have to
wait for the serious catalog to come and
you'd have to go to the lingerie
section and he goes now with the
internet i can just go to sears.com
it's such a good joke like it's such a
great like joke do you
have any rules with your kids about the
internet
porn sex talk like how do i don't even
know where to start
no i don't i mean look here's the thing
when my kids were little i said to both
of their dads
here's both boys both boys when i was
pregnant and i found out
they were boys somebody said to me oh
you're lucky because if you have a girl
if you have a boy you only have to worry
about one penis and if you have a girl
you have to worry about all the penises
but in the world the best text that i
got from my son the other day he's 15.
okay he shall remain nameless i one day
when he gets older i'm gonna post this
on instagram
okay so i'm it's 9 51 at night i get
this text
i'm buying a ball trimmer on your amazon
it's 70 dollars and i literally thought
we have those manscaped we have i
thought but here's me
i thought it was like a for a basketball
like maybe there i don't know
and then again even before i respond you
can't say no
because i need it again this is there's
no vowels in any of these texts
you're like paid all this money for a
private school and love you
okay so i write back to him your balls
need trimming
and he writes like the surrounding hair
you know what i mean again no vowels
all right now it's 9 51. you can't use
the scissors
how much ball hair is there and then i
was like what am i doing
whatever i don't want to know buy the
ball trimmer and he's like i already did
and then i was like how do you have
access to my amazon account anyway
that you go to that instead of why do
you need to trim your balls why do you
have access to my amazon
he needs to trim his balls he needs to
trim his balls it's okay with me
so to answer your question i don't know
what he's watching what he's seeing
remember
i'm their mother yeah it's not exactly
like they're thinking that they're gonna
go into the world like slapping people
around yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm slapping them around right
right so i think that they both have a
great
deal of respect for women yeah and
um if you're shaving your balls that is
very respectful
yeah i mean he knows he's disgusting i
appreciate that
you've trained him well he's probably
like going to be listening to this
somewhere going
yes using family members for fodder paid
for my house
so honestly uh uh that's funny you say
that because last night um
i was ordering uh some valentine's day
like the guy that i'm dating loves
lingerie
like he's into it and it's not the sears
catalog there's this guy not that
i do i am so now that i'm in full like
sports bra sears catalog like totally
done with lingerie i'm dating a younger
guy
um and he's very into it uh
and i'm like i'm just used to getting
older guys that don't get they're like
taken they've seen it all they've done
younger guys they're like into it right
they're like want they've only watched
porn they see a human woman in lingerie
they're super excited i'm like what is
this
go watch porn like he's super
independent when you're ready i know
i'm like go jerk off to the sasha gray
or whoever the porn star like why
like i'm not used to guys wanting to
like have sex with me and have it go on
for a while
do you find more and more that's making
me think about like
she a lot of i'm finding more and more
couples are breaking up over like
online affairs cheating
texting like yeah but again that stopped
a lot because
of covid now you've got what do they
call it like a like it's a platonic
relationship like they never do anything
but they're confiding in each other
online emotional cheating right or
emotional affair
emotional affair that's a big one that's
a big one and it's not okay
because by the way i i don't i would
rather that my significant other went
and fucked a stripper
then i shouldn't say that i don't mean
to demean strippers if you're a dancer
that doesn't necessarily mean that
you're gonna have sex with somebody's
husband what i'm saying is a hooker yes
then have an emotional relationship with
someone well that's
huge because i was in a relationship
with where i lived with somebody
i had an emotional affair with somebody
one who was like an authority figure
to me a mentor someone that i like
looked up to
whatever my dad didn't show up pick me
up from school on time it's the older
men's my thing
um and it was like i wasn't cheating but
i was checked out
right i was emotionally with this person
right and it was like
you know and this is such a male female
thing and i know we're not allowed to
say men and women are different now
that's like a hot take i'm all right i
get it
um but it was this thing that was like
but we're not
having sex we talked on the phone for
three hours and he understands me like
no one else understands me and he sees
i'd prefer
20 minutes of sex and let's talk about
things you know
and he made me understand he was like
this is like me just
get because my sort of
primal carnal need is to emotionally
invest with someone his primal
carnal need is just to get come out of
his balls you know
so he's like this is the equivalent of
me just getting a hooker
and of course i'm jealous of this right
like but there's no sex like
so i think elizabeth gilbert put it as
always um she
i think i've said this before the
podcast closing the doors and windows so
it's like if you have something
that you want to share emotionally
that's a big deal at work right
don't share it with your co-worker like
if something big happens right
because then you're not gonna need to
share you're not gonna have anything to
talk about when you get home right save
it the same way you save
your semen for your person right don't
jerk off right before you have sex
don't emotionally invest in your
co-worker if you're going to go home and
have dinner with your person
like hold it in and it's taken me a long
time that's a gross
fucking metaphor but that has helped me
a lot to be like oh my god this big
thing happened and i really want to tell
because i have so many platonic guy
friends that i work with and
then i'm like you're my soul mate and
it's like no i just
you were just there right you know what
i'm saying
and then you build this case that the
person you're with doesn't understand
you or doesn't see you
it's like you just didn't tell them
right that whole time you were investing
in right
you couldn't tell them the same way
because you had already given the good
tell
to jim from accounting right you were
given all the you're good they're the
first take of the story to jim from
accounting and by the time you get home
you're like
okay i just i've already told this story
like well i didn't
ask you to have told it already why were
you telling stories to someone at work
you should have been working
why are you emotionally investing in
them in gym it is tricky
because it is also like we forget like
women haven't been in the workplace
that long this is the first
yes but they've been in the workplace as
long as we've been working working
that's true but so it's not like we can
say like well we don't
understand what it's like by the water
cooler all i've ever known is the water
cooler
i'm not like i finally got into the
workforce when i was like 40 and my kids
were
already in school and i'm like going
back to work i feel like i have to
remind guys though sometimes when i'm
working in a workplace with guys and
we're talking a lot that we're not
together
right i maybe this is maybe this is a me
thing because i have bad boundaries
or something but and maybe i work in a
business that's very emotional and
we share personal stories in writer's
room and actors and whatever maybe
it's a codependent job but when i'm like
sitting next to a co-worker
for like five or six hours and we're
talking and there's a
moment where you know at the end he's
kind of like oh can i help and i'm like
no we're not dating no that doesn't
happen in family life really
i feel like there is no boundaries in
the workplace
yeah that i think that has to do with
what you do that's more what we do for a
living yeah i definitely think so i i've
been in writer's rooms i've seen how i
mean that's
much more familial and sexy and cool
whatever yeah
not so much interesting yeah you guys
don't fuck around you know about
you know the players having affairs with
people i mean it does happen you're
there all day
all day all day it's also why people
fuck their nannies
because that's the person that's in the
house taking care of your children you
have to actively
be on watch you have to actively be on
the defense when it comes to that i
think that's what i'm trying to say it's
like when you're in a workplace and you
might get tricked into thinking that
this person is really close to you and
you're
have this connection it's you're just
working together we're not like we just
went through this like work trauma
together we just made this deadline
we're just like the best and like we're
such a great team and like
bye maybe we should be together like no
now i'm gonna go home
right it's like when you get trapped in
an elevator with somebody for 45 hours
you're not soul mate and you get out and
you've had this experience but guess
what
anybody could have been trapped in the
elevator with you you have to
take into account that we are incredibly
irrational emotional creatures and we
get swept up and we get
flooded with oxytocin and we make bad
decisions
yes you know because i wouldn't yeah
yeah this is what
are which our rational behavior pays for
all of your cars
um but yeah so i just that's such a
fascinating
like i just feel like ultimately i'm
just too emotional to be able to do what
you do and i'm just so fascinated how
you're able to like turn it on
and off and when you're in
like i like to call them uh growth
opportunities not fights
in relationships like d are you able to
be emotional do you turn it off like are
you
i was thinking about that before when
you were saying you argue with your
boyfriends and you love it i don't
have that many fights in my relationship
well who how dare that who's gonna
how imagine being a guy who's like
yeah i'm gonna fucking watch this what
like jesus
no i think you probably just you i feel
like if i am gonna be
experiencing conflict i wanna be
getting my 9 15. so so i don't have that
much
that's why i'm not funny in a
relationship so i'm like this is my job
yeah i think that truly here's so many
comedians and i've met so many comedians
you actually are funnier than most of
the ones
really i feel like i'm bombing unfunny
no we're not that funny in real life
which is why podcasting is such a
like um which i was so excited when you
had a podcast cause like that's who i
want to listen to talk from
that's why i want to hear talk for three
hours laura wasser comedian like i've
already heard your
you talk about it right yeah like it's
like comedians
were not that funny when we're not doing
stand-up well i think and
many lawyers i can't speak for many
lawyers for myself
i was did not have big arguments and
again it might have actually been bad
like i probably held stuff in that i
otherwise should have been saying or
arguing about
because i just i think a lot of times i
was like i just
i don't want to fight i don't want to
argue about it i don't want to talk
about it choose your battles though but
i also think that's super healthy to
have the restraint of pen and tongue and
to go this is worth fighting and this
isn't
right i think that's like one of the
biggest skills in a relationship of like
i know i could fight you on this and win
but i'm going to let you ha
let dropping your ego right right like
just going like this was fucked up
this person made a mistake i'm right but
i'm not going to say anything right
like that's like if you want to stay in
the ring right and i'm also a very big
fan of the email
that you sit with for a minute you don't
just
not the text message but the email where
you really write it out like you were
saying like
i make my point and then i did it i do
that in an email defend my
yeah i let it sit i don't send it that
night i wait i don't know
when i'm still angry and is it whoo and
then i read it again and i will often
edit but then i send it because i do
want the person able to read it and then
it's not just me like slapping you with
it there read it
you can sit with it you can come back
you can read it again you can think
about it and i
feel again this probably is being a
lawyer and being the daughter of two
lawyers yeah
the written word is very important it
stays it's there you have it you can go
back and find that email when he says
well you never even told me that
bothered you yes i did on february 10th
can i 17 i sent an email and told you it
bothered me honestly
put it in writing like this is going to
be our next merch launch put it in
writing
like with benton and all the new people
working here who aren't here today
because we're
covered protocol but we normally have
like lots of people here um
spreading germs uh and uh you know
put it in writing is like a huge thing i
mean i went through a crazy lawsuit
a couple years ago not saying that this
is even for lawsuits but
you know our memories aren't always
reliable we get emotional
we get carried away feelings aren't
facts and
it's just like can you just write that
down and send it to like i'm that's like
my new
biggest tool my my big tool uh
uh is for when people ask me to
do something and i don't want to i'm a
capacity i'm sorry i can't do that
like that's one new tool another new
tool is like can you just put that in an
email
just so i could like put everything in
an email your boundaries
your fears your resentments when you're
not emotional so you have it like for
your own
database of your emotions you know
you've sent it to this that's right i'm
not crazy well you told me this
no i didn't like basically do
um what what is it evidence like make
sure you have evidence for your own
case that you're gonna have to build in
the future you have to live your life
thinking you're gonna have to build a
case but for your own self to know
because not people don't always hear you
when you speak
that's correct you don't always remember
whether you've said something or whether
you just thought
god i should have said that so now if
you have it in an email
huge yeah there's times where i was
talking about this today
where i'm like no i said i told you this
it was important to me it's like no i
felt it and i thought
i've just thought about it so much that
i assumed you knew right
and we make these assumptions that the
person we're with can read our mind
and it's such that's such a genius tool
to just have stuff in writing
not to go i did it just right to know
that you're not crazy right
like yeah no i i did ask you to come to
this box i bought you a ball trimmer
in february of 2021. why
is there's pubes everywhere i thought we
shaved these
but like but that is like that is
honestly the
biggest problem in my relationship right
now now when i get an altercation
with my person i have to remember like
we're on the same team
i forget because i'm like it's about
fucking winning it's me versus you
but once you're in a union it's if
if i win we both lose right right and
that's how it divorces too by the way
like i say to people all the time this
you have one family okay
the more money you keep within your
family instead of spending it on me
being hurt forensic accounting and
whatever
keep it together and here's the other
thing i might be looking
really good do you right now i assure
you that 6 12 18 months from now
we're not going to be talking to each
other every day right but your ex-spouse
you're still a family member with invest
in that
you are all on the same team even if you
don't feel like it right now
yeah yes and it's so hard for me because
i
i get in the mode of fucking winning i'm
gonna fucking win this right but you can
win it
but like you said the way the mindset
changes i can win it by us both winning
define winning
is winning mean you're right and the
person the puddle of mush on the ground
no
and the per is that what you want you
want something is we are either about to
go to dinner or get in bed together and
watch a movie or have sex
the only way to win this argument is we
go have sex after and we never talk
about this again
remember charlie sheen winning see oh
god
that's my definition of winning why do i
feel like you had to deal with that
why do i feel like he's been in your
inbox one too many times
but i think that that's something i
forget my ego gets involved
and i get into my victim mentality and
i'm like
i need to fucking hurt you instead of
whereas it's actually self-care to shut
your fucking mouth sometimes
and put it in writing and make a
positive investment in your future self
by going you know what i'm gonna like
become cool and
collected and i'm not gonna let what i'm
saying get lost in how i'm saying it
yeah
because i i have this theory that
when you're arguing with your person you
your first 30
is this like being a lawyer your first
30 seconds you're you've either won or
you've lost
yes i definitely think that you're
opening that's why they call opening
statements opening statements are so
important so important because it's
you are summarizing the case for the
judge and we don't have jury trials and
family law but if there's a jury as well
right from the get-go the evidence will
show this is what i'm going to tell you
now you have the whole case it's super
boring you have the evidence it tells
them
and then you do a closing statement
where you're like remember how i told
you at the beginning this is what i was
going to tell you
i did i win fuck off
how do you like i'm obsessed with you
how do you craft an opening statement
it takes a while and again good ones i
mean my dad used to say
every case has a theme so and again
family law how many themes can there be
but like
we had one yesterday oh my god it's all
zoomed now so i had a case did you hold
on the
did you i'm sure you saw the guy that
was the cat
while this woman yesterday my opposing
counsel was giving her opening
i was watching the cat when he like
looks to the side
and then he goes i'm actually really
here i'm not a cat
it was brilliant
i watched it like 12 times and one other
one with a kid like writing a scooter
into a wall that i kept watching over
and over again that i'm like
what's wrong with you like is he going
to win that case
i don't know how annoying the judge was
and he's like well let's keep going and
the judge is like no let's
get the cat off first we're trying and
the guy doesn't realize i'm sure
how like ridiculous it is it was it was
also not really such a
cute cat it was just like i know
it's like it's as a viewer you kind of
want him to stay a cat
i think it would have been would have
sound better but it was very similar to
what i was watching
yesterday when this woman
and the case is still going and i can't
talk about it but this this
video that she constructed to be part of
her opening statement with music
and pictures and and and my client
texted me because we were not together
because we're doing it on zoom
oh my god is this really happening and i
was like i'm so embarrassed for my
entire like trade like that this is
happening right
even the judge i was watching him and he
was like i mean made like a video to try
and manipulate or try to show
tell her story sorry i had pictures and
there was music and there was a little
animation and it was in evidence this is
an audition tape
it was unbelievable yeah for the amazing
bar mitzvah
it was just it was yeah we're fascinated
with lawyers
humans we're fascinated by lawyers and
the most popular shows on tvs are
lawyers
on tv right what is that well we
just looked up like the cat we were
talking we were talking about your honor
which is great yes
but then um did you watch not not the
good wife but the good fight did you
watch that
oh is it great oh my god so good again
it's now
it but it's amazing it's got some of the
same cast members they've broken off it
was
very very timely in terms of like trump
and what if hillary clinton
won in the 2016 election it's so good
they're so smart
but remember there was la la i mean
there's all why are people so obsessed
with this
i don't know but i know like you said
people have often tried to make a show
that had to do with like
you know the divorce the family law
realm and they don't work
because it's depressing yeah that's
right that's the thing we want to see
criminals go down we don't want to see
someone lose their kids right
and also you know really the business of
family law i mean look you've got stuff
you're dividing somebody's getting
support like it's just not that
interesting
interesting is the human emotions that
go along with it
and i guess you could write a 30 minute
every week about that i mean i don't
know
but those those shows have not worked
and i'm also i'm a
i'm not a it's harder to be a woman in
stand-up person at all
i'm like i feel like i got some things
that i didn't deserve because i was a
woman and then i had to like pull it
together and go like oh shit i gotta
like earn these opportunities that i
just got
you know because i like there were a
bunch of dudes and i was a girl and they
were like we need to put her on a lineup
like i got a couple opportunities that i
probably was not ready for frankly um
but uh have you ever been in a situation
where you're like
i feel like i'm not allowed to lose my
temper like that i feel like i'm not
allowed to get emotional
i feel like if a guy gets emotional he's
like passionate and intense and he's
good at his job but if i get emotional
i'm like a crazy bitch
yeah but again that i don't i also think
when a guy does it that he's
might i am a big my i came up with my
father saying basically like never let
him see you sweat
my i never saw my dad get angry he never
got angry in an argument he always was
very soft-spoken
my brother and i would know if my dad
was mad it was because we could barely
hear him
i mean that was what was scary to us so
to me somebody flying off the handle and
being angry
man or woman they just lost they lost
their shit literally
and you know i have opposing counsels
that will you know say
make cutting remarks say mean things
that doesn't help them i
see what judges are able to see
and i can tell that that's not helping
but people can't help themselves and
that's what you don't want
in a representative or a lawyer you want
someone who's able to really
really hold your cards close to your
chest make the best argument that they
can for you we were talking a little bit
before about the tattoo
that had less to do with like my boss
feeling like a tattoo
was you know female or racy i mean we
literally i would wear glasses
and i didn't need glasses but i wanted
to look older and i wanted a little to
look more serious yeah
it's about you know and i had guys that
i went to law school with that had nose
rings or ponytails and the the
teachers said look you never know what
your judge is going to be thinking so
you want to take yourself kind of out of
the equation can you be fashionable
can you look attractive yes but you want
it to be about the case that you're
making for your client
and your client also by the same token i
have had to take clients
we our offices in century city over to
the westfield mall buy them a suit
because they're punk rockers and they're
like have tattoos and a torn t-shirt and
i'm like dude
let's go i mean you know you have to
dress accordingly because
the law is something where you are
putting your best face forward yes
whether you want to have custody of your
kids pay less money people always say
what do i wear
well if you're going in and you're
asking for spousal support because
you've been out of the workforce for so
many years
don't wear blue suit you know
tie on the column you don't have to wear
a costume yeah yeah yeah you're wearing
your flashiest with your air masks
wear a wedding dress right that's when
you should wear it
when am i gonna wear this again or wrap
yourself you know people like
show up just people always say like what
i do with this wedding dress
wear to your divorce trial this is diet
black
to be on an episode or something um
viewers reminded me of something like
you know we talk a lot on this podcast
as someone that
talks a lot uh and has a very
adversarial relationship with talking um
because it's like what i do for a living
but when women do it too much it's
annoying and like
someone put a dick in her mouth it's
like i feel like there's a
i have a very um tight tight leash in
terms of
when i'm she's powerful she's strong now
she's annoying and crazy and obnoxious
and
nag and shrill and whatever um but
it it is such a helpful reminder i think
at this time
when women want to be like and i'm gonna
fucking say what i think and i'm gonna
be outspoken or just in general the sort
of
the younger people that i work with are
like i'm going to say my feelings all
the time and i
want to tell them like yes being
authentic great
saying what you feel great but the real
power
is shutting the fuck up
measuring twice cutting once and when
you speak
saying something incisive uh clear
cogent and then people actually fucking
listen when you talk yeah and when you
speak softly
people also often lean in to hear what
you're saying instead of
leaning back because you're yelling or
being what could be perceived as
offensive
literally the art of seduction 101 it's
like
we had robert green on the podcast to
talk about all that um which reminds me
of i did use to date a guy that used
that in a very manipulative way where
um when we would get in fights if i lost
my temper he would start talking quieter
and quieter
he'd be like why are you why are you
yelling like
what are you why are you freaking out
okay you're like i'm sorry what yeah so
like what and then whatever you do
sounds so loud
it was like his way of making me crazier
than i was
like why are you yelling i'm not yelling
like it's just like no it seems like i'm
yelling because you're
whispering um that is uh
that one didn't work but uh but yeah i
just
i just think that that is something that
i as someone that's been fascinated with
you and has watched you for a long time
and as i'm trying to figure out what
being powerful looks like
what it sounds like i got the wrong
programming
right i thought it was like loud
aggressive you have to talk the most
say the most in the meeting be the
loudest
and it's taken me so long to realize
that it's not true power
it's it's a it's like a huge lesson yeah
that i feel like
you know even with social media and
posting it's like
more is not always more right sometimes
and you know
and then what do you ever want to this
is like a totally geek law question
do you want to go first
no not usually how do you get who
decides that
if you file the motion then you are
usually the one that's going first
because you're the moving party
so you present first right so i want
this
and so i'm gonna make my you know and
then the other person says well i don't
want to give you this and so it's this
so
i mean it depends and most of the time
you know who's gonna go first but once
in a while
somebody will like will position or
whatever i don't really care either way
i mean it also depends on how long the
trial is if you
if you're going to go first and then
there's not going to be another hearing
for a month then that's not
an advantage because you want to be the
one that the judge remembers yeah yeah
you're doing it all in one day i mean i
don't care
okay here she goes can i just keep
staring does that creep you out when i
just stare you
no i'm just fascinated by what what who
like i feel like i rush people
when i because i talk so fast and i'm so
that i'm just working on
talking slower so that you don't feel
rushed i don't feel rushed
really no one rushes you no i just no
i'm sure people do rush me i used to
have a lot of like pressure to get out
of the house but that doesn't happen so
much since covid um
are you scared of anything
do you get scared yeah i'm scared of
getting old and i'm scared of something
happening to my kids i'm not
really scared of dying but i literally
like we were talking about that
boy who overdosed like i am terrified of
something happening in my kids and
and when i started law school i
obviously didn't have kids
the law school professor on like the
first day like says to this big
classroom of students like how many of
you have kids because some of the people
were going back to school
raise their hands and he said law school
is like having kids it never
goes away for the next three years it
doesn't matter how wasted you get or if
you're on a vacation or you're a family
wedding
it's always there and i didn't totally
understand
it because i didn't really have that
experience in law school i liked law
school and i
had a really good time in law school and
remember i got engaged and then married
and yeah
so it wasn't i thought it was neat
having kids like they're always there
there's no day off when you when you
have kids a cell phone is a whole
different thing like i have to i don't
the way you look at that phone
it's like it's like every it's a heart
attack every time all the time
when they're little but now i mean no
it's always no
it's scarier now they can drive where is
he is he in discomfort is he in pain is
he sick
did you know something fall or hit him
or whatever
all the time and i'm a very easy going
mom they will tell you that but by the
same token you
always they're always there and you want
them to always be there
you don't drink the same way so you
don't do drugs the same way
no past travel the way that you used to
because you always are thinking
how am i going to get back in time i
mean it's a totally different thing you
don't
you don't even hang out with the same
people necessarily that you used to
because if there's somebody that you
would be embarrassed to introduce your
kids to
you don't want to hang out with them
it's really cool i know i hung out with
a friend of mine and her kid the other
day and the kid shit in my yard how old
is the kid
like four weird it was it was really
weird i was like i get why you don't
bring this kid around
it's kind of
[Laughter]
but yours also like it's funny because
it's like when
the the people you used to like party
with in your 20s start having kids
you're like you're exactly the kind of
parent i thought you were gonna be like
well it's true you become friends with
people who parent the way you do i was
gonna say
when you become a parent you don't your
childhood doesn't change right you don't
all of a sudden become a super
responsible person that knows what's
appropriate right
you just pass it on to your children but
it's like i remember there were certain
people i was friends with and their kids
like run through my house with chocolate
on their hands or nutella and i was like
oh we're not hanging out and they
wouldn't do anything yeah
oh wow are we gonna do something about
this kid or not
you know if my kid was at somebody's
house doing that i would like have him
in like a
chokehold don't you feel like people are
too permissive with their kids now
it depends i mean not all of them are
yeah some of us are a little too like
helicopter
yeah yeah yeah it's a balance and again
going back to what i said earlier you
can't judge you never know
why someone's acting the way they act
right it happened to them what happened
to them with their kid you know so you
just got to kind of
have you ever like been in a parenting
situation we were like ah should i
handle that differently
yes try having a teenager
i mean you know especially now there's
no blueprint for what's going on
yeah and i'm i've always spoken to my
kids
like they were little adults and i think
and that's how my parents spoke to me
and my older son is very much like me
my younger son is very different from me
in all the best ways but there are
sometimes i will say things to him that
i would have said to my older son where
i can see this look on his face or i'm
like
i shouldn't have said that that's he
doesn't take that the same way and
that's not okay
oh interesting because i was going to
say like you practice on the first one
the second one your kids are different
they're all kids are so different and
you really realize when you have more
than one kid like they are different you
can't just i mean certain things yeah
like you know this is how often i gotta
take them to the doctor yeah yeah yeah
but certain things you really and i
think i i think i'm an okay parent you
have to focus on that kid it's not a
cookie cutter and so
yeah you you grow with them you learn
with them i mean you know my little one
had
more anxiety issues whatever instead of
saying like you're being silly or get
over it which i could say to the older
one and he would
and which is what my dad said to me this
one i have to sit with and say let's
talk about that and how does that make
you feel and whatever and it's been a
really good
growth experience for me as a parent and
as a person i mean like
yeah they're so good now boys have
emotions who knew
yeah oh he yeah he has them and also
it's helped me with my older kid too
because i can't just
but just because my parents treated me a
certain way doesn't mean it was though
well the circumstances are very
different now yeah yeah it's like it's
it's i i hear a lot of it
as not being a parent i hear a lot of
people complaining about zoom school
and i was talking to um you know my
therapist who works with children too
like
yeah i'm like is this so traumatic for
kids and they're in mass and they're on
zoom and like it's like parents are it's
actually harder on parents
right because we want kids to have the
childhood we had right whereas there's
like this is preparing them for the
world they're gonna live in
right but they can't have the childhood
that we had and in some ways it's better
like we have to like let them
like be the in the world that they're in
yes
my parents used to say go play until it
gets dark and then come back i can't say
that to my kids
it's illegal now to do that right
my mom used to say go out and play come
back before
dark right but i didn't we didn't know
when it was going to get dark
it would get dark and then you'd fucking
have to like blair witch project your
way home
and like you go to a house i'd go like i
don't even know because my house was
virginia i got in the mean streets of
the flats of beverly hills there wasn't
so much blair witch project
it was like bart scorsese actually doing
the camera work
it was actually steven spielberg um
but uh but yeah so it's i'm fascinated
by that because i see so many uh
of my friends now who are like trying to
be great parents and they've got the
organic
apple butter and the organic almond
butter and i'm like
dude we did anyone else drink out of a
hose when they were a kid i think out of
a hose sat in the way way back my
brother broke his arm because we got
rear-ended and i slammed into him
because we didn't have seat belts i mean
our parents were drinking and smoking
not saying it's right just saying like
we'll probably live my kids never had
sugar cereal until one time we were
down at the beach and i went into the
store and they had the fun packs of like
oh the little ones
yeah oh my gosh oh it was like i
couldn't even see it oh
there are nine of those a day it was
just fruitless yeah fruity pebbles
pretty pretty pebbles the cinnamon toast
crunch apple jacks
applejack oh i used to mix apple jacks
and cinnamon toast crunch yeah
and i used to put oreo cookies in a bowl
and put milk on it and eat it like
cereal right and then they
and i i turned out great and now i'm 38
and my hair is blue things are going
great but no it just grows like this
but it wasn't the fruit loop you
probably hate too many
lucky charms as a kid i also pee this
color is that weird
um but i uh uh i yeah i'm obsessed
because i see all my friends and they're
so like
and then i had a friend uh she came over
and they're putting all the sunscreen on
the one that the kid that shit in the
backyard because that explains
that okay that actually it's all the
same parents so actually because she's
like do whatever you want but then she's
super
neurotic about no chemicals no
gluten i'm like my mom i used to drink
like cough my mom's
coffee that does that does i think we're
off a little bit with the second one
you're kind of like ah yeah is that why
the second one's always shorter
no i don't think so they're not getting
as many nutrients
i have noticed everyone's second kid is
just like a little off
my my second kid's shorter because his
dad's shorter so that
would be yeah yeah yeah he's just gonna
be shorter but there's something about
the nutrients like uh uh the second kid
gets less yeah but have you noticed that
kids today are so tall
i think it's because of the milk the
gmos yeah
all that stuff i know they're huge which
is weird because our yeah like
apparently they're growing ball there
like
i know i don't know whatever's going on
in your house
i don't know if the rogaine in the water
over there
but i am i do think though there's
something uh
when you talked about wearing glasses i
do think when you're a woman and you're
in a
professional situation there are limits
to the accessories you can wear
like you've kind of changed my um
internalized sexism around this like i
feel like whenever i put on a pair of
glasses
at work everyone's like ooh sexy libra
it's like
no i need glasses right i need to wear
like as a woman if you put on
accessories you're in a porn
all of a sudden but you're like but
again i'm older and i've got credibility
i wouldn't i don't
have any of that yeah when i was in my
20s interesting
30s but like i go down to los angeles
superior court
many of those judges have seen me
through two pregnancies wow
if they don't know me they kind of know
my name
and they're like not going oh look at
this tart if i'm wearing like you know
five inch christian louboutin or
whatever
interesting so again you have to kind of
earn that and i hope i have changed
it a little bit for women because look
one of the best things about making big
money is being able to buy
yes yes yes i have a couple more
questions then i'm let you go cause you
have a dinner
yeah is it a dinner yeah a work dinner
no really
mel is my best friend and it's her
boyfriend and then this other friend of
mine
do people set you up a lot i bet no
really
would you want to set me up that wasn't
a question
i don't wish any of my friends on you
see
yeah but i do i and i can't really go
and bumble
you can't you're too rich for that so
what do you do
i i i you're like i do okay
no i know but i'm curious this is like a
question people ask me like where do you
meet people and like i never know how to
answer it
but it is a i just do i mean again i was
in a relationship for seven years
until a year ago so and now we've been
in covet
yeah yeah yeah so thank you because i
wanted to talk so much about like
getting the nitty-gritty but also
your insights on just relationships and
conflict and just
i wanted to really talk to you like as a
person and thank you for letting me uh
do that welcome it's fun what do you do
your skin the last thing
i get a facial once a month your skin is
sickening but that's because of my mom i
have good
genes what is ja greek no it's russian
russian russian oh yeah yeah yes
and she had a really good skin and we
both spent too much time
in the sun and um facial once a month
with cindy karimi
and i use lemare products okay i love
you don't ride elephants laura will be
[Music]
back
[Applause]